foreign
he witnessed his father commit a brutal
crime and what's what's the crime
well he committed murder in front of him
who to kill
[Music]
um he found his longtime girlfriend in
bed with the band
[Music]
what up what up what up this is John
with the Dr John deloney show
so glad that you're with us
greatest mental health and marriage and
parenting podcast ever recorded YouTube
show all of it so glad that you're with
us if you want to be on the show give me
a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask all right here's uh vulnerability
time
I am re-recording the intro to this this
show this is uh this is future John
reviewing what past John did
so I recorded this episode and as soon
as it was over I was just sick to my
stomach for a couple of reasons
um I wasn't in a great headspace going
into this show and instead of being a
grown-up and having a hard conversation
with Kelly and the team saying hey
today's not a great day I got stuff
going on my personal life just a lot
going on
um I went ahead and did it and I ended
up
I think uh blowing a couple of calls
and normally I would edit this out and I
would take it out um and y'all would
never know what happened and it would
just be a private little moment between
me and the caller and would never see
the light of air or sweet Sarah would
edit around it all and try to make me
look good and the reason I think it's
important to put these calls out in this
way is number one they happen in the
same show I was having a bad day and
number two I think it's important for me
to be able to say hey here's where I
messed up and I want you to take this
lesson into your lives into your
marriages into your friendships into
your dating relationships and your
relationship with your kids
um because
sometimes expertise is having the right
answer in the right moment and sometimes
expertise and wisdom is about saying hey
now's not a great time let me Circle
back let me go for a walk around the
block give me 30 minutes I need 24 hours
to think about this and let's Circle
back so in this first call
a woman called
um about her husband and his weight gain
and the way she described his weight
gain and
um
you can you can hear the call but it set
me off in a way that I ended up
allowing myself
I I'm not gonna say I got dragged into
it I entered into her
um toxic relationship I joined in and I
became a part of a really messed up
Dynamic that as a as the person she was
seeking counsel from wisdom from I
should have stayed Above The Fray I
should have stayed outside of it and I
didn't I got involved and by getting
involved I neglected a really important
piece of wisdom for her and her husband
which is he needs to go see a medical
doctor asap
because he's had some dramatic life
changes and I did focus a lot on
potential depression focused a lot on
her behavior and actions and the way
she's treating him and talking to him
but because I got carried away and I got
frustrated in the middle of that call I
allowed myself to get in the middle of
this thing where I didn't belong
I I missed I missed Healthcare 101 which
is man if you've got some significant
weight gain some significant life
changes and you're not well
go see your doctor asap start there
start with a blood test start with a
relationship with your primary care
physician or a specialized doctor start
there and I got carried away and so I
blew it and so I just want to say that
up front as you listen to this call know
that the first thing I should have told
her was
hey you gotta love this guy B
he needs to go see a doctor today all
right so here's my call with Jane from
Houston Jane from Houston here we go
what's up Jane
hello Dr Delaney how are you um
I'm good but I can already hear it hi Dr
Maloney how are you what happened
well um I'm
our marriage my husband has gained a
significant amount of what at least 70
pounds
and it greatly affects our activities we
can do together
be it from just taking a walk going for
a hike
in our sexual activities
and
I'm just feeling like I want more and he
refuses to do anything to improve his
health
and so
my quandary here is on one hand I feel
resentful about it that there's a lot of
stuff we can't do together eat like I
say even just going for a walk
and then on the other hand I say okay
fine I'll just go do my own thing
explore my own hobbies and uh do you
want to get back
I don't want to build up resentment and
oh you're way past that you're way
better I know you're way past that I
know a woman being resentful come on
okay listen
um
genocent usually I get like one or two
lines Jenna sent
a big chunk of your original email
can we go to the can we go to the bottom
of it
okay I don't have it printed out not the
bottom of it like get to the bottom of
it
what you just presented
was this
um
concerned wife who's just worried about
the health of my husband
and I think that I think that I think
that's true
but here's what you wrote okay I'm gonna
read it back to you okay
my husband has gained over 60 pounds
since we married 12 years he drinks at
least a six pack of beer throughout the
day in a nightcap or two he eats out all
the time and eats so much junk food
his weight gain has affected our sex
life in his prior marriage his wife did
one thing to do with him
and refused to have sex with him
therefore since he had nothing else to
do he was the workout King he was so hot
why did she get hot Mike and I only get
Fat Mike I enjoyed our sex life early in
our marriage and I don't know what to do
he has bigger boobs than me or his boobs
are bigger than mine okay so that's a
different level of disdain there tell me
about that
the
one of those is like I'm a concerned
wife I'm worried about his health we
can't do things together and I'm I'm
starting to feel alone
one of them the other story is
his first wife got the good mic and I
got the leftover bum mic and what kind
of bum am I married to that's a totally
different track here talk me through
that no well because every other
fact he's great and wonderful but
I pretty
take care of himself and be healthy and
now he claims he's happier than he's
ever been and yet he just keeps getting
bigger
so I mean you hear it as you ask it
right
right tell me about his ex-wife
we've already made this conversation
weird we're gonna get super weird all
right tell me about her
apparently she has mental health issues
okay yeah I'm only hearing his side of
course and there is every excuse for not
being intimate afraid of having kids
didn't want to mess up the kids and
you know
every excuse for not being intimate and
so he said well I had nothing else to do
so I just worked out okay just between
you and me that's nonsense okay
um
what
moves sex over to the side tell me about
her
what did she demand of him
he put her through graduate school okay
as far as
she demanded of their relationship I
know nothing beyond that
that was long before we met okay what do
you demand of him
I want to spend time together in doing
stuff
how do you get there
currently all we can do together is
involves sitting and eating or drinking
but this is not a big drinker this
didn't happen overnight though true so
true early in our marriage
it was we were working you know raising
a child and we're both working 60 80
hours a week and
you know our sex life was great
oftentimes you know you hit the bed and
you're exhausted both of us equally
exhausted and reach over you know hey
babe I love you I really want you I'm
just you know the body's weak we're
exhausted
you know
and but now we've raised our child he's
moved on with life and
my husband had this picture the the
child leaves a nest and over right we're
gonna be having rocking sex all the time
but he's gained all this weight
and it is sex's ability to perform and
so now his solution is I should
do other things that
I'm not particularly interested in
you know let's go to a strip club I want
to see a stripper give you a lap dance
you know as a woman that's not a turn-on
for me yeah and you
so
and ew
um
that actually that actually more
confirms what I thought
um
he's quit
he's completely given up
he doesn't like who he's become in this
new life
and since he's not on the phone I can
only talk to you okay and what I hear
is a woman who does not like her husband
you love him dude I love a lot of people
that I can't stand
but you don't like him
I want to deal with it
do stuff
oh you're trying to a hundred percent
agree with you
but you're trying to protect yourself
and I need you to stop for a second
you don't like him
and I don't think you've liked him for a
long time
I'm just disappointed
and there is oh man there is no greater
way to to
deflate a man than to look at him and
say I'm disappointed in you
and if you've been disappointed with him
over this my guess is over time you've
been disappointed in him a lot now I'm
not blaming you from where he's where he
ended up this has been his choice his
decision and now he's grasping at straws
because he doesn't like who he has
become
and so he is looking for ways to
increase his heart rate
that's why he's going to keep coming up
with more wild and more wild and more
wild because he has to deflect this
issue and make it not his make it yours
the same way you've deflected this issue
for years and made it all his
and if I'm wrong tell me I'm wrong I'm
willing to be wrong
no I can
I can see that
my guess is in
now how to be careful how I say that
um
I don't know that he sees any value in
what comes next
other than to keep you from hassle on
him
and whose son was it was it your son to
bring to the marriage or was it his mine
yours he loved that boy
yes absolutely
um
I'm wondering if putting his first wife
through grad school and feeling like he
had a role to play there
even though that role killed him because
it wasn't reciprocated
and having a young man to raise stepping
in that boy's life and seeing him off to
his next adventure
and it sounds like a guy without a
purpose
other than just to stop being hassled
well I help him find that purpose
you gotta first tell them that you like
him that you're on his team
not just he's not performing for you and
he's because he's gotten too fat
and that you got ripped off in this deal
your whole language is you got you got
you got ripped off
instead of seeing I've got a hurting man
in front of me who's dying here and my
trying to beat him up all these years
all the over all these things
that's not working
yeah and I don't feel I've been beating
them up because I only approached it a
few times of hey let's go for a walk
let's do something together I would be
willing to bet money I don't have a lot
but I'd be willing to bet money that
if I was talking to him
he's had a hard time making you happy
over the years is that fair or no
I don't think so
just out of the blue he just suddenly
went from super hot
um always in the gym always working out
to suddenly
having to drink himself
to a a coma every night
no you know
when we got together neither of us was
working out because we didn't have time
we were both working a couple of jobs
and you know now our child is raised
you know we're both self-employed we're
debt free
let's find something that we can do
together let's
you know enjoy life do something go see
the country or something but do you see
anything
you don't like your life either
I I hope you can see the dance that's
happening here
is you got a guy who doesn't like who
he's become
and so he blames himself
and he's going to slowly eat and drink
himself to death
and he's got a wife who doesn't like who
she's become
but heaven forbid she blame herself so
she blames him
for the life that she's getting ripped
off from
and it becomes this weird wobbly dance
that nobody wins
until either he drops dead or you leave
so how do I help him find
who he wants to become
I believe in the marriage I love them
you know and I want him to be happy and
I want to fulfill his dreams and
Fantasies
he's he's got to be involved
yeah
foreign
counseling with you
probably not
why not
he went
in previous in his previous marriage and
it went nowhere
okay
so been there done that the working out
been there done that didn't work in the
previous marriage and so
you know watch out again
yeah I don't I don't do diagnosis on
this show but that's a depressed guy
who's done he says stop
you've heard of the diseases of despair
correct it's a lonely guy
and again in no way am I excusing him
I'm just trying to paint you a picture
that the path to his heart the path to
what comes next the path to building
this life you want to have with him
where y'all are just living your best
self now that you got kids out of the
house
the path to him is not through
strip clubs and the path to him is not
through
um hassle in him and calling him fat
and making fun of his boobs and
get on to him about his drinking
at the end of the day here's the truth
you can only
control one person on the planet and
that's you
and so what I would recommend for you is
if he won't go with you it's his loss at
this time
but I would go see a counselor myself
and not one to
the whole call the whole approach here
is there's something wrong with him
but you can't fix him what you can fix
is you and so I want not that you need
to be fixed but learn some new dance
moves learn some new ways to navigate
this relationship
and I would tell you to start with I've
got to ReDiscover do I like this guy yes
I'll love him you'll love him for the
End of Time
but do I like him
and does he know that I like him
but I don't think that's where you start
I think there's one layer beneath that I
think you start with
calling a counselor and during the
intake when they say why you want to
come
I want you to tell them I don't think I
like who I've become
I've become somebody I don't want to be
and I've participated in creating an
environment where people aren't healthy
or I'm not healthy my husband's not
healthy but I can't do anything about
him I can only do something about me
and I need to get back in touch with the
the woman that I love
that I like
so that I can reach out and let my
husband know that I like him too
but you sound bitter you sound
frustrated and I'm not saying you
shouldn't be man it sounds like your
whole relationship's just sideways
and you bet you got a husband who's
given up
just want to give you a little bit of
Hope
sometimes it just takes a little bitty
spark to set the whole place on fire
and maybe by you going to do the work
that you need to do for you
[Music]
he can be inspired he can see the light
coming on in the house again
he can see that woman look across the
room and say I like you
[Music]
and I'm willing to work on this thing if
you are
[Music]
that's my best guess here and if he
wants to call on the show I would love
love to talk to him Jane I would love to
if he would um if he'd do want to call
if he does want to call let Jenna know
and we'll get that set up ASAP
I'm rooting for you man I'll help any
way I can if you've got some specific
questions man but this
um someone's got to turn the lights on
and stop the music and say we're not
doing this dance anymore
I'm getting well I hope you'll join me
we'll be right back
hey deloney here hey you know a while
back Society went off the rails and
people started to see sleep as like an
annoyance it's something in the way
right just chug another energy drink and
keep hustling and grinding my friends
sleep is not the enemy it's essential to
the way our minds and bodies function
and there are several things you can do
right away to start getting better sleep
first lay off the caffeine especially
after like 10 or 11 A.M and ditch the
screens at least an hour before bed and
I recommend getting a great mattress and
you can get a great mattress from my
friends at dreamcloud I speak from
experience here the right mattress can
make a huge difference in your sleep
quality it's why my family sleeps on
dream Cloud their mattresses are
designed to be soft and cool and
supportive so you can sleep comfortably
all night and right now dream cloud is
offering my listeners 25 off your order
plus 50 in additional savings and 500
199 bucks in accessories when you use
promo code John deloney that's cooling
pillows luxury sheets and a mattress
protector so go to dreamcloudsleep.com
and use code John deloney today
all right we are back and as I discussed
at the beginning of the show if you're
just picking up with us
um a couple of these calls on this
episode I blew it one of them I got
involved in the actual dysfunction of
the marriage relationship and I got
carried away I allowed that to happen
and so I ended up getting frustrated
with the caller I ended up missing a
crucial piece of wisdom in this
particular call you're about to hear
it's Anna from Tulsa and Anna has a son
um And that son watched her his father
kill somebody
and
I've got stuff going on in my private
life I've been on the road I haven't
been taking care of myself very well my
diet is about that of a second grader
turned loose in his parents pantry and
um
I was immediately thrown back to some of
those crisis calls that I went on with
especially with kids especially with
kids that saw things that they should
never have seen kids trying to make
sense of awful things that their moms or
dads had done either to them or to
somebody else
and so you're going to hear in this call
I Stumble through it a lot and I get
quiet a lot and I just there's long gaps
where I don't say anything
um and
again normally we would edit this stuff
out or I wouldn't have taken the call
it's rare that I blow it this bad but I
thought it was important this time for
this one reason
if somebody comes to you with some hard
information and it's not a good time
it's always okay to say hey I really
want to be there for you I need 30
minutes I really want to be there for
you I can't meet right this second can
we meet at 5 pm tonight can we meet
after the kids are in bed gonna take you
to breakfast in the morning
so this is me being vulnerable this is
me showing you um man sometimes I step
up to the plate and I just miss
um and um this isn't a a pivotal moment
in Anna's life
and um
I showed up but I wasn't fully there
check it out
but to Anna Anna Tulsa what's up Anna
hi Dr
today rocking on how are you
pretty good
10 year old son after a huge live change
he witnessed his father commits a brutal
crime and
um
his father will be gone for a long time
and I know
well he committed murder in front of him
who'd he kill
Ed
um he found his
longtime girlfriend in bed with the band
and
um it was the next door neighbor
he's
what a mess
how many years did he get
it's it's still going so
so before we go any further can I just
tell you I'm sorry I'm so sorry your
whole world's exploded I'm so sorry
thank you
and I know you love your little boy he's
on the phone with us right now we can
talk about him in a minute but I'm just
so sorry
nothing's ever going to be the same and
you didn't ask for this and didn't I'm
so so I'm just so sorry
foreign
well it was just unexpected
it was a
nuclear bomb that went off in your
neighborhood and it detonated directly
in your house and I'm so sorry
my gosh
what a mess
for those of you listening
um
I've had to walk into that home too many
times and hug too many Annas over the
course of my career and so I'm kind of
speechless right now just because I know
what's next
um
okay I'm not gonna put my story under
your story Anna so let's talk about you
how how have when did this happen
uh at the beginning of December
so we've had a little bit of time to
well I was about to say this is like
yesterday you've had no time
foreign
you know why because he's he's 10.
yeah that's why I'm worried about you
and I want to go out on a limb just by
talking to you saying you're struggling
is that right
yeah that's right it sounds really like
your ability to toggle in and out of
being unable to breathe and you feel
like if you start crying you're never
gonna be able to stop too it's okay it's
great
pretty much
if you I can't tell you how to grieve
because everybody does it differently
but I want to tell you the longer that
goes
the deeper those grooves get man that
gets real hard
and I know you feel like you have to be
the rock in the wind for your son and
there's some truth to that somebody's
got to make sure he eats and is fed and
he's still got connectivity especially
after the hell he's been through and
Hell he's going to go through
but the greatest gift he could ever have
in the world right now is a mom that's
honest with herself and with him and
with the world around her okay
yeah
he's gonna need a a strong balance of
stability
and he's gonna need a mom who tells him
the truth when she's devastated and
heartbroken okay okay
don't hide your grief from him it's a
gift it'll be a great gift to him
[Music]
okay
that's my promise my promise my promise
my promise
God I'm so sorry
you should
you say it's been been a while it's been
it hasn't it's been like a few a month
two months right two and a half months
um
has your son been asked to testify yet
he has been and that's that's kind of
where my my question really is is how do
we handle that because his his
grandmother his paternal grandmother is
trying to
she's trying to manipulate his testimony
and
um get her as far away from that boy as
possible yeah there's an order in place
now so good good
it's just hard with his questions you
know like when can I go see them when
can I you know
oh man okay
um let's walk through this from the tip
top okay
he's gonna always know
that half of him is Mommy and half of
him is Daddy
okay
in the dance you're gonna have to do is
gonna be a difficult one
because
you're gonna have to let him know that I
loved your dad but I did not love what
like what he did and he's gonna he got
in big trouble for what he did because
what he did was wrong
but the moment that switches to I hate
him
I'll never love him again I'm pissed off
at him he ruined our lives that 10 year
old boys can internalize that because
half of him is that guy
and then on the other hand you got
grandparents telling them how great he
was and it was just a moment of whatever
and it was for self-defense it was a
moment of passion
and so he's going to be thinking yeah
it's I guess I guess the scariest most
sickest moment of my life was from a
good guy see how confused this little
boy is you're right
oh man
so
he's gonna need in short order like
today tomorrow right and this isn't all
fall on you this falls on some
caregivers and that's why I can't stand
it when adults act like idiots like his
grandpa like his grandparents are
well and you know I can't call them
idiots because they are trying they love
their son and they're they're in the
same I get it
um he's gonna have to know
that he is wonderful and magical and
able to overcome things but he can't
just get that with words
what does that mean that means you're
gonna have to give him a bunch of little
opportunities to be successful and so
are his teachers and so are his aunts
and uncles that you trust and so are
friends of parent uh parents friends
he's got to have chores he's gonna have
to have a bunch of little wins and when
he has success in little places everyone
needs to Rally around and point it out
look what you did great job look how
hard you tried
right and if we just wrap our arms
around him and tell him you're so
wonderful and great and perfect and
lovely and all that
there's going to be a disconnect and
what his body feels and what his brain
knows
so it's got to be through accountability
it's got to be through action okay
whether that's a join a jiu jitsu or
playing baseball or whatever and you're
going to have to be prepared for him to
love love love his dad and be so mad at
you that he can't go see him every day
and then in short order hate his dad so
much that he can't breathe
and then go right back to loving dad
because he can't hate him too much
because that means he hates himself do
you see I mean it's just it's gonna be a
dance from here out right right
um
a friend of mine
who does this for a living works with
these kids
um she's just a savant she's been on the
show actually
um
everybody's going to want to get to your
kid because he's a prosecutor's dream
and he's a defense attorney's nightmare
right
yeah has he already testified or is it
coming up or how's that working
it
[Music]
in the court yet they're still working
on that process but he's already done an
interview and did you interview with the
with the psychologist or with the judge
in his Chambers or her
um he did he did uh
well they started with play therapy to
get to get it uh going and and the
prosecutor said that that is uh going to
be strong in the case because they just
don't want he hasn't really talked about
it and they don't they want when it
happens to be as organic as possible and
so he hasn't really spoke about it or
anything
um he has a therapist he's going to
weekly but that's still they're still
building a relationship so um I would
write this down tfcbt
trauma-focused cognitive behavioral
therapy
it's extraordinary and it's actually
pretty systematic
um and what it does is it teaches him
how to feel safe in his body when his
body sounds every freaking alarm that it
has which it will
because there's going to be moments of
Terror and rage and self-hatred and
hatred of dad and hatred of you and
hatred of everybody
and that little body doesn't know how to
handle all that and so what
trauma-focused cognitive behavioral
therapy does it teaches kids how to take
deep breaths and how to lengthen the gap
between stimulus and response and how to
feel safe in your own body and what to
do when you don't feel safe so it's a
lot of skills he's going to learn in a
pretty systematic way
um
and if it's possible there in uh Tulsa
where you live I would seek that out
okay okay
um
[Music]
what's I'm and I feel like I'm just
talking man I'm making your story mine
I've just been through down this road so
much and it's just so heartbreaking for
me and I know it's heartbreaking for you
you're living in hell I mean you're
I mean your your glasses are tinted in
red and fire because you're living in
hell
um
any specific questions I can help with I
feel like I'm just rambling I'm so sorry
no but I appreciate everything you've
said it's been very insightful in the
situation
um my my big question is
when
this is over with and he has been
sentencing everything how do I talk
about because I've already set the
boundary I'm not taking him to visit in
the jail and I'm not going to uh
entertain phone conversations where he
he's trying to put stuff in his head and
so I want to just be able to to I was
thinking okay well you can write letters
and then when you're 18 we can give them
to Dad or you know if Dad wants to write
letters I'll give them to him when he's
18 but I just want to make sure that
he feels like he's being heard because
now you know his dad is gone yeah
yeah
um so part of the boundary is keeping
your kids safe and if in short order or
if over time
there is an understanding that if your
husband is able to say or your
ex-husband are y'all divorced now
we were never married okay all right so
um if he is able to say things like
Daddy really messed up big time
and I hurt somebody really bad
and so I had to go away
if he takes ownership for the fracture
in the relationship
that's the sign that
um I will entertain some communication
but if there's some I got screw you see
what I'm saying he needs to own dad and
son are not together because of
something dad did not son
okay
and I don't think he's there yet and I
don't think he will be for a couple
years that's and that's his choice and
and I think in a way to articulate that
doesn't mean you get the phone doesn't
mean you get
um a bunch of visits
up right up front
um
what you don't want to do is be the
person that
is so enraged by what he did and so
enraged by the embarrassment and the
shame and all that stuff and how he blew
your life up and blew your son's life up
that when he's able to say
this is 100 on me and son I'm looking at
you and I'm proud of you and I believe
in you and you're not going to be like
me
when he can say those words those words
Will be Like Oxygen in that little boy's
lungs
but it also takes a sense of maturity
that
somebody who hauls off and just kills
the neighbor doesn't might not have
right
and so I think you're wise to not allow
connection right now and I think you're
wise to allow letters and I would allow
letters and read the letters and if
there's nothing bogus or dumb in them I
miss you son and I can't wait to see you
someday and all that kind of stuff I
don't know yeah I'm thinking out loud
um you know what I'm just an idiot on a
podcast work with this psychologist on
that
um I'm I'm
angry right now on your behalf and so
it's clouding my judgment a little bit
because my thoughts right now is that
guy deserves to never talk to that
little boy ever ever again as long as he
lives
and I want that boy to not know that man
ever existed except he can't because
it's his daddy and he probably looks
just like him and he saw everything that
happened
yeah and and you know if he writes
letters and he does
take ownership then I think that would
be a different story it's just when he
has done this and then he talks on the
phone about how he wants his mom to to
get our son to manipulate the testimony
it just it confuses me so bad because I
don't understand how you would you would
you know first you've committed this act
in front of him and now you're trying to
to re-traumatize him and you know
convince him that he didn't see
everything that he saw right
yeah he used to be as far away from that
man as possible
that man's lost the right to
um have have connection with the Sun
and I'm not saying that's forever but
that's certainly for the foreseeable
future try to weaponize a kid after what
you did to him God help you man
I'll tell you this
um it's going to be very easy to go to
autopilot
please fight that with all you can
what that means is you're gonna have to
feel this and it's gonna be
unimaginable pain
and I'll tell you you can't do it by
yourself
do you believe me when I say that
do you believe me
I do believe okay
so hear me say the greatest gift you can
get your son is for you to get a couple
of good friends for you to get a
counselor for you to get some friends at
your church I don't wherever you've got
people and set up a regular time that
you can meet and even if it's two or
three girlfriends that you text and say
hey
I'm going to need to speak openly and
to word vomit sometimes
and I'm gonna need someone to walk
alongside me I've picked you all two or
three or four if y'all are in every
Monday at 10 or whatever every Tuesday
at whatever time
if y'all will be there for me as often
as you can I'd be eternally grateful
okay I can do that and you keep showing
up and you keep showing up and you keep
showing up
and you'll ask each other what's one
thing you did good for yourself this
week which one thing you're grateful for
what's one thing you are just devastated
heartbreaking for
because you're gonna have to fight the
urge to check out to just numb through
this because it's going to hurt that bad
and if the defense attorney's doing
their job their job is to
make the world believe your 10 year old
son is a liar
and it will make you feel and see rage
like you've probably never experienced
in your life
and if he has a your son has a good
attorney then their job is to defend him
from that nonsense and that evil
right
let me say it this way let me see it
this way
everything in your life is different now
and the sooner
um imagine your house caught on fire
and all of a sudden the ceiling starts
caving in
and you put up one hand to try to stop
it and then all of a sudden the beam
starts falling over here and so you
reach up over there and then the floor
starts bubbling up and you've got one
foot like over you know trying to keep
the floor up
the sooner you just get out of the house
and let it go to Ash
which is where it's headed and then you
can start the cleanup process and start
imagining what's life going to be like
now
it's not any easier
but it's a whole lot less psychological
Devastation because you don't have you
don't have all that wasted energy trying
to hold this thing together everything's
new now okay
that makes sense
and it's okay to be so mad
so mad
and so heartbroken and so everything
that little boy is going to need the
word the nerd word we use as Attunement
um
attachment he's gonna need to know that
his mommy sees his eyes and feels his
heart
and that he can see her eyes and feel
her heart even when her heart is sad
okay okay
and I keep saying this I'm so sorry
I shall head through this process
um please please please
um don't hesitate to call keep him away
from media keep him away from
well-meaning aunts and uncles if you do
have aunts and uncles come over or
friends or whoever feel free to say
do not talk about Dad don't say you look
just like him don't say so glad that
you're not whatever or nothing he's not
mentioned in this house right now the
only person with permission to mention
Dad is is your little boy that's it
and we're not we're keeping away from
yeah so keep away from media
keep up the good work with him in
counseling
[Music]
make sure you take care of yourself
I'll be with you every step of the way
call anytime I can help
so so sorry my goodness we'll be right
back
hey good folks John deloney here
I fell through a glitch in The Matrix
this is my job I get to have this show
do this show walk alongside each one of
you as a career this is what I do and I
have a blast doing it and me and the
team were so thankful for all of you for
being a part of our show whether you're
one of the original 17 or you're one of
the millions that's come since then we
are so grateful for you and we want to
put together the best possible show that
we can so if you're one of The Originals
or if you're brand new we want your
feedback tell us what you love about the
show what you hate about the show would
you like to see more of what you like to
hear more of and what you want us to
never do again you can email us at
askjohn ramseysolutions.com that's ask
John
ramseysolutions.com with your feedback
thank you for being such an important
part of the show rock on
all right we're back let's go to Robert
in Chicago what's up Robert
hey John thanks for having me on the
show of course brother you're doing well
today
um we're getting there man what's up
uh so I was uh I was raised Christian
growing up um but I've pretty much been
an Atheist my whole life okay
um my wife is also an atheist but she
believes that religion is brainwashing
and it's bad okay I disagree with her on
this actually I actually I follow
scripture and religion and and I like
hearing about it like on the Ramsay show
okay
um I want to send our kids to a private
Christian school and maybe church if
they're interested in going
um so am I doing the right thing
um how do I guide them in life but not
push them and how do I approach my wife
on this
hmm
feels like there's like five questions
five questions there I'm sorry
um so I
let me let me say back to you what I
heard okay
um you don't believe in the
fairy tale somebody's listening to all
of your the Harry Potter parts of the
Bible but you like the structure you
like the morality you like the if you
follow these rules you're probably gonna
have a better life if you don't kill
people you're probably gonna have a
better life if you don't lie and cheat
and steal right so you like that part of
it and you like the structure
your wife on the other hand thinks
that's the problem with everything all
the world's ills are because of
religious people
yeah
yeah I think you got it yep that's it
so why do you want to send your kids
there because you wanted to learn that
structure or just because it's
comfortable because that's what you know
uh because I want them to learn that
structure and I like the conservative
background and the good principles that
it teaches so what happens if one of
your kids comes to you and says daddy
will you baptize me in the name of
whatever
Jesus Christ are you in would you do
that for them absolutely okay
um
and here's why I'm asking that
it's a tall order
for a kid
what's the right way to say this I'm
struggling with my words
um
if you send a kid to a private Christian
School they're gonna get the
Christian message
right
they're gonna get the full package and
as a child they as much as our
overly sophisticated
Parents try to make kids which is just
so insane what we do to kids these days
they will not be able to differentiate
as little kids they just won't
and what I mean by differentiate they
might be able to know like I don't know
if Santa Claus is real that possibly but
and it they won't be able to
differentiate I think
teacher so-and-so is lying to me that's
where it gets more challenging okay and
so if you're sinning them just for the
structure but you're gonna fight them on
the other things they learn and what
they the other things they come to on
their own then I would suggest maybe
that's not that's not you're going to
confuse your kids
um if you are sitting them there because
no man I want them to be open hold
belief with an open hand
and I'm gonna honor and support and love
whatever they come back with
then I think that's that's pretty
amazing of you and good for you and I'll
be all for it where are you going to run
into problems if mom is trying to
torpedo this whole thing y'all got to be
on the same page
yeah that makes sense yeah
is she totally against this
I've mentioned it a couple times at
first she totally was but recently I
kind of brought it up really quick and
she kind of warmed up to the idea
what do you want uh I meant the
Starbucks line and by the way can our
kids worship Jesus Christ Lord God
savior ready to go that's pretty much
what it was
[Music]
um yeah I wouldn't do it like that
um yeah I've been kind of like testing
the waters
you're ridiculous but but but
I understand so uh I think it's worth a
sit-down conversation
have you sat down and had that full
conversation with your wife like you
explained to me
no no I haven't not about your kids but
about you
um yeah yeah we've talked about that
okay and she still married you anyway
why
because she loves me oh
I love lots of people I'm not married to
Robert
is she gonna be okay if your kids come
back as believing Christian kids
yeah yeah
she would be okay
so
what's your question
I I guess
just how do I how do I approach her on
this what kind of how should I start the
conversation and
and feel her out on it
uh I don't
I think you're trying to be awfully
political on a really important topic
and so I think Honesty and directness
and dignity and respect are the approach
here not
strategies and tactics
um I would sit down if I was you and say
okay they've reached age X we both don't
like what's happening in public schools
partridge in a pear tree whatever store
narrative that y'all have talked about
there
I drew great benefit from the structure
from the morality from the kindness from
all those pieces
from this structure and I want to give
our children an opportunity to have that
same
structure
this is important to me would you allow
us to to give us a shot and here's
here's the other thing that I I talk to
parents all the time about homeschooling
and private schools and this and that
and you can always just switch
right
yeah if your kids come home and say hey
I gotta work on my memory verse and
your wife just goes into a
you know a rage just start setting a
house on fire you can always just put
your kids back in public school
yeah yeah that's true too is that fair
yeah yeah definitely
um I guess my other question too was is
how do I guide my kids down this path
but not push them you know how do I know
when when they don't want to continue
with it if they're maybe they won't tell
me
I don't know that they get a vote
that's a lot of pressure to put on a kid
if there's abuse I'd say in my house I
missed it
um we put my kid in a private school uh
wasn't a faith-based school it's just a
it was just a private school and they
had a lot of beliefs that we had like no
screens and you know they learned math
by
doing things like building things and
cooking things and things like that
super hippie school is awesome
um what I didn't know is that my son's
teacher
couldn't stand him
and that he was really struggling with
connectivity with students and I blamed
him and I told him things that I'm
ashamed of like suck it up you got to
get over it dude you need to quit fill
in the blank until one day my wife had
the courage to go down there and she sat
down and talked to everybody we and we
had both talked but with the different
people but she finally got it and she
picked our kid up and walked out the
door
and we have never been back
and so when it comes to hey we're going
to this school I think a lot of times we
give kids that option and that's that's
choice is so heavy on them
and that's a burden that I'm not going
to put on my kids hey we go to this
school this is the school you're going
to
except if they're being abused
if they're in a situation where the
adults in that school don't like my kid
don't want my kid to succeed want my kid
to not be there then I'm gonna gladly
I'll help you out and I'll take my kid
out other than that I'm not going to put
him in that situation so I would tell
your kids hey we're going to a new
school how old are your kids
well just one right now how old
one years old yep oh my gosh lead with
that Robert a one-year-old
one-year-olds don't even can't
you especially don't get a vote until
you can poop in a in a toilet
Fair yes Fair
um
man I thought your kids were like nine
and six or something okay so you have a
one-year-old yeah they don't get a vote
homie just Cinema School
okay
you are way overthinking this
yeah that's what I do
yeah how about don't do that man you're
gonna make yourself nuts
all right
um if yeah yes
just put your kid into school he'll
they'll be fine
um I think you need to be prepared for
what happens if are we gonna honor our
kids belief that the same way we expect
other people to honor ours
and I say that same thing to my friends
who are Christian whose kids come and be
like I don't know if I buy all of this
I always tell them you have you are not
a Crossroads that the kid just laid
before you
are you going to choose a relationship
in the long-term game here
are you going to choose
dogma and being right right now
one of those May cost you your
relationship with your kid forever
and I'm not saying parents give up on
their belief kids he's nice they're
gonna go to church with me all that
stuff is still gonna happen
but I'm talking about beating kids up
over belief which I've been working at
universities my whole life that that's
I've just seen it over and over and over
and over again parents sacrificing the
long-term relationship with their kids
over small battles and so you're gonna
y'all you and your wife gonna have to be
totally on the same page when it comes
to that
because trying to torpedo a
three-year-old or a four-year-old with
well you know that's not true I mean
that's just man it's just cruel quite
honestly
and Robert he's won
one years old
I know that you know this but you've got
the rest of his sweet little life to
worry about him
just put them in school
and if you choose a private Christian
School fantastic great
um
honor the rules and regulations and
honor the spirit of the place
and be supportive of the teachers and be
supportive of the curriculum and don't
get mad when they teach things that you
don't necessarily agree with because you
signed up and sent your kid there
or do what I do I send my kids to public
school
and I have taken ownership in my home of
their spiritual Direction and the things
that they are learning and I'm actually
grateful for the stuff that they learn
in the public school because they come
home and ask me about it and I get to
teach them before they head off into the
real world and learn about it and don't
have me they have Google instead
and so that's just the path I've chosen
I don't know there's a right or wrong
path here other than a mom and dad who
are completely and totally attached and
attuned to that kid
and are willing to sometimes
keep their mouths shut and say that's
very interesting tell me more about that
what does that look like
I would love to know more what do you
think Daddy oh I'm not telling you that
that's just for me I love hearing what
you have to say about
that's hard
that's the long-term play
the long game we'll be right back
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships I'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's own your past change your future
at John deloney.com
all right we're back as we wrap up
today's show this was a heavy show it's
unexpectedly heavy
um
and I talk too much in this show I
apologize man hopefully Sarah can edit
it down these calls I I just kept
talking and talking and talking a couple
of them
got me in a way that usually calls don't
get me but a couple he's hit pretty
close to home so uh sorry for rambling
so much Today's Show thanks for sticking
with us uh man can't go wrong when
things are down with a little JT Justin
Timberlake can't stop the feeling goes
like this I got this feeling inside my
bones and it goes electric wavy when I
turn it on all through my city all
through my home we're flying up no
ceiling when we're in our Zone I got
that sunshine in my pocket got that good
soul in my feet feel that hot blood in
my body when it drops
my body drops I Can't Take My Eyes Off
it moving so phenomenally
standing use of the word phenomenally JT
room unlock the way we rock it
so don't stop I may talk too much but
we'll never stop we'll see you soon love
you guys
[Music]